you wrote
gato is not the end it's the beginning
and then he wrote meow and then an emoji
of a cat
uh so first two questions first can you
explain the meow and the cat emoji and
second can you explain what gato is and
how it works right indeed i mean thanks
thanks for reminding me that we're all
exposing on twitter and
permanently there yes permanently one of
the greatest ai researchers of all time
meow and cat emoji yes there you go
right so can you imagine like touring uh
tweeting
meow and cat probably he would probably
would probably so yeah the tweet is
important actually um you know i put
thought on the tweets i hope people
which parts you think okay the
so there's three sentences
gato is not the end
gato is the beginning
meow cat emoji okay which which is the
important part the meow no no
definitely
um that it is the beginning i mean i i
probably was just explaining um a bit
where the field is going but um let me
tell you about gato so
first the name gato comes from maybe a
sequence of releases that deepmind had
that named uh like used animal names to
name some of their models that are based
on this idea of large sequence models
initially their only language but we are
expanding to other modalities so we had
a you know we had
gopher
chinchilla these were language only and
then more recently we released flamingo
which adds vision to the equation and
then gato which
adds vision and then also actions in the
mix right um
as we discuss actually actions um
especially discrete actions like up down
left right
i just told you the actions but they're
words so you can kind of see how actions
naturally map to sequence modeling of
words which these models are very
powerful
so
gato was named after i believe i can
only from memory right this you know
these things always happen with an
amazing team of researchers behind so
before the release yeah um we had a
discussion about which animal would we
pick right and i think because of the
word general agent right and and this is
a property quite unique to gato um we we
kind of were playing with the ga words
and then you know gato
yes um and gato is obviously a spanish
version of cat i had nothing to do with
it although i'm from spain
wait sorry how do you say cat in spanish
gato oh god okay yeah no okay okay i see
i see i see you no it all makes sense
okay how do you say meow in spanish no
that's
i think you you say it the same way but
you write it uh is m i
a u it's universal yeah all right so
then how does the thing work so you said
general is
so you said
uh language
vision
and action action
how does this
can you explain what kind of neural
networks are involved what does the
training look like and maybe um
what you are some beautiful ideas within
the system yeah so
maybe the basics of gato are not that
dissimilar from many many work that
comes so here is where the the sort of
the recipe i mean hasn't changed too
much there is a transformer model that's
just the kind of recurrent neural
network
that essentially takes a sequence of
modalities observations that could be
words could be vision or could be
actions and then its own objective that
you train it to do when you train it is
to predict what the next
anything is and anything means what's
the next action if this sequence that
i'm showing you to train is a sequence
of actions and observations then you're
predicting what's the next action and
the next observation right so you you
think of of this really as a sequence of
bytes right so take any sequence um of
words a sequence of interleaved words
and images a sequence of um maybe um
observations that are images and moves
in a tied up down left right and these
you just
think of them as bytes and you're
modeling what's the next byte gonna be
like and you might interpret that as an
action as an action and then play it in
a game or you could interpret it as a
word and then write it down if you're
chatting with the system and so on um
so gato basically can be but can be
thought as inputs images
text
video
actions um it also actually inputs some
sort of
proprioception sensors from robotics
because robotics is one of the tasks
that it's been trained to do and then at
the output similarly it outputs words
actions it does not output images um
that's just by design we decided not to
go that way for now um that's also in
part why it's the beginning because
there's more to do clearly
but that's kind of what the gyto is is
this brain that essentially you give it
any sequence of these observations and
and modalities and it outputs the next
step and then you off you go you feed
the next the next step into and predict
the next one and so on
now
it is
more than a language model because even
though you can chat with gato like you
can chat with chinchilla or flamingo
it also
is an agent right so that's
why we call it a of cato like the the
word uh the letter a and also it's
general um it's not an agent that's been
trained to be good at only starcraft or
only atari or only go it's been trained
on a
vast variety of data sets so what makes
it an agent if i may interrupt the fact
that it can generate actions yes so
when we call it i mean it's a it's a
good question right what why when do we
call a model i mean everything is a
model but what is an agent in my view is
indeed the capacity to take actions in
an environment that you then send to it
and then the environment might return
with a new observation um and then you
generate the next action this actually
this reminds me of the question from the
side of biology what is life
which is actually a very difficult
question as well what is living
what is living when you think about life
here on this planet earth and a question
interesting to me about aliens what is
life when we visit another planet would
we be able to recognize it and this
feels like it sounds perhaps silly but i
don't think it is at which point is the
neural network
a being
versus a tool
and it feels like action
ability to modify its environment is
that fundamental leap
yeah i i think it's it certainly feels
like action is a necessary condition to
to be
more alive but probably not sufficient
either um yeah so sadly consciousness
thing whatever yeah yeah we can get back
to that later but anyways going back to
the meow and the twin legato right so
um
one of the
leaps forward and what took the team a
lot of effort and time was
um as you were asking
how has gato been trained so i told you
gato is this transformer neural network
model's actions um
sequences of actions words etc
and then the way we train it is by
essentially pulling data sets
um observations right so it's a massive
imitation learning algorithm that it it
imitates obviously to
what is the next word that comes next
from the usual data sets we used before
right so these these are these web scale
style data sets of people
um writing you know
on on webs or chatting or whatnot right
so that's an obvious source that we use
on all language work but then we also
took a lot of agents that we have at
deepmind i mean as you know deepmind
we're quite um
you know we're quite interested in
learning um reinforcement learning and
learning agents that play in different
environments so we kind of created a
data set of these trajectories as we
call them or agent experiences so in a
way there are other agents we train for
a single mind purpose to let's say
you know control a 3d game environment
and navigate a maze so we had all the
experience that was created through the
one agent interacting with that
environment and we added this to the
data set right and as i said we just see
all the data all these sequences of
words or sequences of this agent
interacting with that environment
or you know agents playing atari and so
on we see this as the same kind of data
and so we mix these data sets together
and we train gato
that's the g part right it's general
because it really has mixed it doesn't
have different brains for each modality
or each narrow task it has a single
brain it's not that big of a brain
compared to most of the neural networks
we see these days it has one billion
parameters um
some models we're seeing get in the
trillions these days and certainly 100
billion feels like um
a size that is very common um from from
when you train this this this job so the
actual
agent is relatively small but it's been
trained on on a very challenging diverse
data set not only containing all of
internet but containing all these agent
experience playing very different
distinct environments
so this
brings us to the part of the tweet of
this is not the end is the beginning it
it feels very cool to see gato
in principle is able to control any sort
of environments um that especially the
ones that it's been trained to do these
3d games atari games um all sorts of
robotics tasks and so on
um but
obviously it's not as proficient as the
teachers it learned from on these
environments not obvious
it's not obvious that it wouldn't be
more proficient
it's just the current beginning part
right is that
the performance is such that it's not as
good as if it's specialized to that task
right so
it's not as good although i would argue
size matters here so the fact that i
would argue always size always matter
yeah that's a different color
but but for neural networks certainly
size does matter so um it's the
beginning because it's relatively small
so obviously scaling this idea up
might make
the
connections that exist between
you know text on the internet and
playing atari and so on more
synergistic with one another and you
might gain and that moment we didn't
quite see but obviously that's why it's
the beginning that synergy might emerge
with scale right my emerge with scale
and also i believe there's some new
research or ways in which you prepare
the data um that might you might need to
sort of make it more clear to the model
that
you're not only playing atari and it's
just you start from a screen and here is
up and a screen and down maybe
you can think of playing atari as
there's some sort of context that is
needed for the agent before it starts
seeing oh i'm this is an entire screen
i'm going to start playing um you might
require for instance to to be told in
words
hey this is the in this in this sequence
that i'm showing you're going to be
playing an entire game um so text might
actually be a good driver to enhance the
data right so then these connections
might be made more easily right that's
that's an idea that we start seeing in
language but you know obviously beyond
this is going to be effective right this
is not like i don't show you a screen
and and you from from scratch you you're
supposed to learn a game there is a lot
of context we might set so there are
there might be some work needed as well
to set that context um but
anyways there's a lot of work yeah so
that context puts all the different
modalities on the same level ground
exactly provide the context best so
maybe on that point uh so there's this
task which may not seem trivial
of
tokenizing the data of converting the
data into
pieces
into basic atomic elements
that then could uh
cross modalities somehow so what's
tokenization how do you tokenize text
how do you tokenize images how do you
tokenize games and actions and robotics
tasks yeah that's a great question so
tokenization is the entry point to
actually make all the data look like a
sequence because tokens then are just
kind of these little puzzle pieces we
break down anything into these puzzle
pieces and then we just model what's the
what's this puzzle look like right when
you make it you know lay down in a line
so to speak in a sequence
so
in gato
um
the text there's a lot of work you
tokenize text usually by looking at
common commonly used sub strings right
so there's you know ing in english is a
very common substring so that becomes a
token um there's quite well studied
problem on tokenizing
text and gato just used the standard
techniques that have been developed from
many years even starting from n-gram
models in the 1950s and so on just for
context how many tokens like what order
magnitude number of tokens is required
for a word
yeah actually what are we talking about
yeah for a word in in english right i
mean every language is very different um
the current level or granularity of
tokenization generally
means is maybe
two to five i mean i i don't know the
statistics exactly but to give you an
idea um we don't tokenize at the level
of letters then it would probably be
like i don't know what the average
length of a word is in english but that
would be you know the the minimum set of
tokens you could use was bigger than
letters smaller than words yes yes and
you could think of very very common
words like the i mean that would be a
single token but very quickly you you're
talking two three four four tokens or so
have you ever tried to tokenize emojis
emojis are actually just
um sequences of letters so maybe to you
but to me they mean so much more yeah
you can render the emoji but you you
might if you actually just yeah this is
a philosophical question is is emojis an
image or a text
the way
we do these things these things is
they're actually mapped to
small sequences of characters yeah so um
you can actually play with these models
and input emojis it will output emojis
back um which is actually quite a fun
exercise you probably can find other
tweets about this um out there um but
yeah so anyways tex there's like it's
very clear how this is done and then in
gato um what we did for images is we map
images to essentially we compressed
images so to speak into something that
looks more like um
less like every pixel with every
intensity that would mean we have a very
long sequence right like if we were
talking about 100 by 100 pixel images
that would make the sequences far too
long so what was done there is you just
use a technique that essentially
compresses an image into maybe
16 by 16 patches of pixels and then that
is map again tokenize you just
essentially quantize this space into
a special word that actually maps to
these
little sequence of pixels and then you
put the pixels together in some raster
order and then that's how you get out um
or in or in the image that your your
your process but there's no semantic
aspect to that so you're doing some kind
of you don't need to understand anything
about the image in order to tokenize it
currently no you you're only using this
notion of compression so you're trying
to
find common it's like jpg or all these
algorithms it's actually very similar at
the tokenization level all we're doing
is finding common patterns and then
making sure
in a lossy way we compress these images
given the statistics of the images that
are contained in all the data we deal
with although you could probably argue
that jpeg
does have some understanding of images
like uh
because visual information
maybe color
compressing based crudely based on color
does capture some
something important about an image
that's about its meaning not just about
some statistics
yeah i mean jp as i said it's very the
algorithms look actually very similar to
they use this the the cosine transform
in jpg um the the approach we usually do
in machine learning when we deal with
images and we do this quantization step
is a bit more data driven so rather than
have some sort of fourier basis for how
you know frequencies appear in natural
in the natural world
we actually just use
the statistics of the images and then
quantize them based on the statistics
much like you do in words right so
common subscript sub strings are
allocated a token um and images is very
similar but there's no
connection
the token space if you think of oh like
the tokens are an integer and in the end
of the day so now like we work on
maybe we have about let's say i don't
know the exact numbers but let's say 10
000 tokens for text right certainly more
than characters because we have groups
of characters and so on so from one to
ten thousand those are representing all
the language and the words we'll see
and then images occupy the next set of
integers so they're completely
independent right so from 10 000 one to
twenty thousand those are the tokens
that represent these other modality
images
and
that is an interesting
aspect that makes it orthogonal so what
connects these concepts is the data
right once you have a data set for
instance that captions images that tells
you oh this is someone playing a frisbee
on on a green field now
the model will need to predict the
tokens from the text green field to then
the pixels and that will start making
the connections between the tokens so
these connections happen as the
algorithm learns and then the last if we
think of these integers the first few
are words the next few are images in
gato we also allocated
the the highest
order of integers to actions right which
we discretize and actions
are very diverse right in atari there's
i don't know if 17 discrete actions in
robotics um actions might be torques and
forces that we apply so we just use kind
of similar ideas to compress these
actions into tokens and then
we just
that's how we map now all the space to
these sequence of integers but they
occupy different space and what connects
them is then the learning algorithm
that's where the magic happens so the
modalities are
orthogonal to each other in token space
right so in the input everything you add
you add extra tokens right and then
you're shoving all of that into one
place yes the transformer and that
transformer that transformer
tries to look at this gigantic token
space and tries to form some kind of
representation some kind of
unique um
wisdom
about all of these different modalities
how's that possible are the
if you were to sort of like put your
psychoanalysis hat on and try to
psychoanalyze this neural network
is it schizophrenic
does it try to given this very few
weights
represent multiple disjoint things and
somehow
have them not interfere with each other
or is this about building on the
um
on the joint strength and whatever is uh
common to all the different modalities
like what
if you were to ask questions is it
schizophrenic or is it uh does it is it
of one mind
i mean it is it is one mind um and it's
actually the very the simplest algorithm
which um that's kind of in a way how it
feels like the field
hasn't changed since back propagation
and gradient descent was purpose for
learning neural networks so there is
obviously details on the architecture
this has evolved the current iteration
is still the transformer which is a
powerful
sequence modeling architecture but then
the goal of this
you know setting these weights to
predict the data is essentially the same
as basically i could describe i mean we
described a few years ago alpha star
language modeling and so on right we we
take let's say an entire game um we map
it to
a string of numbers that will all be
probably image space and action space
interleaved and all we're gonna do is
say okay
given the numbers you know ten thousand
one ten thousand four ten thousand five
the next number that comes is twenty
thousand six which is in the action
space
and you're just
optimizing these weights be a very
simple
gradient like you know mathematical is
almost the most boring algorithm you
could imagine we settle the weights so
that given this particular instance
these weights are set to maximize the
probability of having seen this
particular sequence of integers for this
particular game
and then
the algorithm does this for many many
many iterations um looking at different
modalities different games right that's
the mixture of the data set we discuss
so in a way it's a very simple algorithm
and
the weights right they're all shared
right so in terms of is it focusing on
one modality or not the intermediate
weights that are converting from these
input of integers to the target integer
you're predicting next those weights
certainly are common and then the way
the tokenization happens there is there
is a special place in the neural network
which is we map this integer like number
1001 to a vector of real numbers like
real numbers um we can optimize them
with gradient descent right the the
functions we learn are actually
surprisingly differentiable that's why
we compute gradients so this this step
is the only one that this orthogonality
you mentioned applies so
mapping a certain token for text or
image or actions this
each of these tokens gets its own little
vector of real numbers that represents
this if you look at the field back many
years ago people were talking about word
vectors or word embeddings
these are the same we have word vectors
or embeddings we have image vector or
embeddings an action vector of
embeddings and the beauty here is that
as you train this model if you visualize
these little vectors um it might be that
they start aligning even though
they're independent parameters there
there could be anything but then it
might be that you take
the word
gato or cat
which maybe is common enough that
actually has its own token and then you
take pixels that have a cat and you
might start seeing that these vectors
look like they align right so by
learning from this vast amount of data
the model
is realizing the potential connections
between these modalities
now i will say there would be another
way at least in part to not have these
different vectors for each different
modality
for instance when i tell you about
actions in certain space
i'm defining actions by words right so
you could imagine a world in which i'm
not learning that the action app in
atari is its own number
the action app in atari maybe is
literally the word or the sentence up in
atari right and that would mean we now
leverage much more from the language
this is not what we did here but
certainly it might make these
connections much easier to learn and
also to teach the model to correct its
own actions and so on right so all these
to to say that gato is indeed the
beginning that it is it is a radical
idea to do this this way but there's
probably a lot more to be done and the
results to be more impressive not only
through scale but also through some
new research that will come hopefully in
the years to come so just to elaborate
quickly you mean
one possible
next step
or
one of the paths that you might take
next
is doing the tokenization
fundamentally as a kind of uh
linguistic communication so like you
convert even images into language so
doing something like a crude
semantic segmentation
trying to just assign a bunch of words
to an image that
like have
almost like a dumb entity explaining as
much as you can about the the image and
so you convert that into words and then
you convert games into words and and you
provide the context in words and all of
it
um
and eventually
getting to a point where everybody
agrees with noam chomsky that language
is actually at the core of everything
that's it's the base layer of
intelligence and consciousness and all
that kind of stuff okay
uh you mentioned early on like psi it's
hard to grow what did you mean by that
because we're talking about scale might
change
uh there might be and we'll talk about
this too like there's a
emergent
there's certain things about these
neural networks that are emergents a
certain like performance we can see only
with scale and there's some kind of
threshold of scale so it why is it hard
to grow
something like this meow network
so the meow network
is is not it's not hard to grow if you
retrain it yeah what's hard is well we
have now one billion parameters
we train them for a while we we spend
some amount of work towards building
these these weights that are an amazing
initial brain for doing this kind of
tasks we care about
could we reuse the weights
and expand to a larger brain and that is
extraordinarily hard but also
exciting from a research perspective and
a practical prospective point of view
right so
there's this notion of
modularity in software engineering and
we're starting to see some examples and
work that leverages modularity in fact
if we go back one step from gato to a
work that i would say train much larger
much more capable network called
flamingo flamingo did not deal with
actions but it definitely dealt with
images in in a in an interesting way
kind of akin to what agato did but
slightly different technique for
tokenizing but we don't need to go into
that detail but
what flamingo also did which gato didn't
do and that just happens because these
projects you know they're they're
they're different you know it's a bit of
like the exploratory nature of research
which is great the research behind these
projects is also modular yes exactly um
and it has to be right we need we need
to have creativity um and sometimes you
need to protect pockets of you know
people researchers and so on but we
believe in humans yes okay and also in
particular researchers and maybe even
further you know deep mine or or other
such labs and then they act the neural
networks themselves so it's modularity
all the way down okay all the way down
so the way that we did modularity very
beautifully in flamingo is we took
chinchilla which is a language only
model not an agent if we think of
actions being necessary for agency so we
took chinchilla we took the weights of
chinchilla
and then we froze them we said
these don't change we train them to be
very good at predicting the next word
he's a very good language model state of
the art at the time you release it etc
etc
we're gonna add a capability to c right
we're gonna add the ability to see to
this language model so we're gonna
attach
um small pieces of neural networks at
the right places in the model it's
almost like
injecting um the network with some
weights and some substructures
in the ways in a good way right so you
need the research to say what is
effective how do you add this capability
without destroying others etc so we
created a small sub network
initialized not from random but actually
from um self-supervised learning that
you know a model that understands vision
in general and then
we took data sets that connect the two
modalities vision and language and then
we froze the main part the largest
portion of the network which was
chinchilla that is 70 billion parameters
and then we added a few more parameters
on top train from scratch and then some
others that were pre-trained from like
from with the capacity to see like it
was a it was not tokenization in the way
i described for gato but it's a similar
idea
and then we trained the whole system
parts of it were frozen parts of it were
new
and all of a sudden we developed
flamingo which is an amazing model that
is essentially i mean describing it is
a chat bot where you can also upload
images and start conversing about images
um but it's also kind of a dialog style
um
chatbot so the input is images and text
and the output is text exactly
um and how many parameters you said 70
billion 70 billion for chinchilla yeah
chinchilla is 70 billion and then the
ones we add on top which kind of almost
is almost like um a way to overwrite its
its little activations so that when it
sees vision it does kind of a correct
computation of what it's seeing mapping
it back towards so to speak um that adds
an extra 10 billion parameters right so
it's total 80 billion the largest one we
released and then
you train it on
a few data sets that contain vision and
language and once you interact with the
model you start seeing that you can
upload an image and start sort of having
a dialogue about the image um which is
actually not something it's it's very
similar and akin to what we saw in
language only these prompting abilities
that it has you can teach it a new a new
vision task right it does things beyond
the capabilities that in theory the data
sets um provided in themselves but
because it leverages a lot of the
language knowledge acquired from
chinchilla it actually has this few shot
learning ability and these emerging
abilities that we didn't even measure
once we were developing the model but
once developed then
as you play with the interface you can
start seeing wow okay yeah it's cool we
can we can upload i think one of the
tweets talking about twitter was this
image from obama that is
placing a weight and and someone is kind
of waiting themselves and and it's kind
of a joke style image and it's notable
because i think andrey carpati a few
years ago said
no computer vision system can can
understand the subtlety of this joke in
this image all the things that go on and
so what we try to do and it's very
anecdotally i mean this is not a proof
that we solved this issue but
it just shows that you can upload now
this image and start conversing with the
model trying to make out if it if it
gets that there's a joke um because the
person weighting themselves don't see
that doesn't see that someone behind is
making the weight higher and so on and
so forth so it's a fascinating
capability
um and it comes from this key idea of
modularity where we took a frozen brain
and we just added a new capability so
the question is
should we so in a way you can see even
from deepmind we have flamingo that this
this moderate approach um and thus could
leverage the scale a bit more reasonably
because we didn't need to retrain a
system from scratch and the other on the
other hand we had gato which used the
same data sets but then he trained it
from scratch right and so i guess
big question for the community is
should we train from scratch or should
we embrace modularity and this lies like
this goes back to
modularity as a way to grow but reuse
seems like natural and it was very
effective certainly the next question is
if you go the way of modularity
is there a systematic way
of freezing weights and joining
different modalities
across
you know not just two or three or four
networks but hundreds of networks from
all different kinds of places maybe open
source network that looks at weather
patterns
and you shove that in somehow and then
you have networks that uh i don't know
do all kinds of stuff like starcraft and
play all the other video games and they
you can keep adding them in
without significant effort
like that maybe the effort scales
linearly or something like that as
opposed to like the more network you add
the more you have to worry about the
instabilities created yeah so that that
vision is beautiful i think um
there's still the question about within
single modalities like chinchilla was
reused but now if we train a next
iteration of language models are we
going to use chinchilla or not yeah how
do you swap out right so there's there's
still big questions but that idea is
actually really akin to software
engineering which we're not
re-implementing you know libraries from
scratch we're reusing and then building
ever more amazing things including
neural networks with software that we're
using so i think this idea of modularity
i like it i think it's here to stay
and that's also why i mentioned it's
just the beginning not the end
you